flaunt my paw okay big fan of the show
I'm Laurie and I'm 92 years old Wow a
rap artist I rap with my boy Frank we're
in quarantine right now so he's not here
we're gonna submit ourselves to plot my
power Brendan you look like the kind of
kid that would call out who [ __ ] their
pants by your [ __ ] in your pants you
guys beautiful beautiful fella right
there huh and what would you catch this
kind of guy on they would use to catch
this fella I would say typically just
prunes perfect huh yeah I like that
throw a couple graham crackers that
becoming this room right now
open-water prunes right yeah they sent
in yeah this was actually they they did
this before King in this thing but he
was like this is just like a sample of
what we do
I'm not mad I'm not mad either man yeah
let him live their life survive the
Civil War the Black Plague and that
hopefully Corona dawg all those guys are
doing it man there's some [ __ ] man
those guys have been through a lot man
those guys are how old 90 years old 75
and 92 5 easy ok that's gonna be you and
Brian 100% I mean he's a young guy
flirting with that older the young dudes
obviously trying to freaking get laid I
bet one of them is by the old guy right
I mean I don't know I feel like at that
age there's an ad for farmers only that
one egg on the left that's pretty nice
body on him yeah
concerning birth his hand in a [ __ ]
oh look at his hand yeah you want that
thing tickling your back yeah you want
backdraft tickle your [ __ ] back do a
trick with these matches Firehouse Subs
over they party daddy so keep it on post
there's a zombie judy has gangrene his
[ __ ] arm we're all gonna pass
[Laughter]
maybe they'll wrap they lived a nice we
rap about that hot rap about that hard
reach rather the [ __ ] third-degree
weekend at Bernie's
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]